>>Craig: When I first started
here 11 years ago, we were slated
to be closed, because we were not
meeting our annual yearly progress
that was expected of us by
the District and the State.
>>Amrita: We had some of the
lowest-performing test scores
in the City, and declining
enrollment.
>>Craig: So we knew something
had to be done, and the staff
and the administration got
together and we decided to put
in place an extended
learning time program.
It was really all about
giving children
that extra time on their academics.
We wanted to see what
the students can do
if they could experience
extra-curriculars
that were really important to them.
So we gave them a whole bunch of
things to buy-into in an effort
to really attend to
these test scores.
And in the end, we saw our test
scores really start to skyrocket.
>>Amrita: A student at the
Edwards Middle School goes
through several classes within
the course of our day here.
On Monday through Thursdays our
school is from 7:00 to 4:30.
And on Friday's, it's a half-day,
and we have professional
development every Friday afternoon.
Through the normal day, a child would
have four core 60-minute classes
in ELA, Math, Science and Social
Studies, and one specialty class.
And then when we launched the
expanded learning part of the day,
the student will go through a
one-hour academic intervention
course, follow by a two-hour
enrichment or electives program.
What we do is we look at
student data very carefully.
We get teacher input as
well as student input.
And we look at what is it that is
going to help drive this student
to the next level within
ELA, Math or Science.
>>Doc: In my Academic League,
which is part of the extended
learning time, I work with core group
of students who are
there for remediation.
And here this is where I
pay individual attention
to specific students.
I have done this for the
last six years with kids,
and I have seen growth in these kids,
because I have them in the morning,
and I have them in the afternoon.
>>Amrita: Our students have
a unique opportunity here,
where we give them the choice
to drive the enrichment classes
that they want in the afternoons.
And so we believe that the
enrichment classes support students
in finding their talents,
working with peers, and being able
to express themselves creatively.
Our Enrichment to Time includes
electives, such as ballet,
step, musical theater, chorus.
And we have several
arts-based classes.
A lot of athletics.
>>Sasha: I joined Stepping
and I love it,
'cause it gives me the
opportunity to express myself.
In a way, I do feel a connection
between my stepping and learning
in class with Doctor Mansaray.
Because I'm having fun while
doing stepping, and I'm learning,
and then in class with
"Doc," I am having fun
and learning at the same time, too.
>>Doc: Extended learning
time is essential.
It builds a school community that
will excel, not only in academics,
but also socially the kids feel safe.
They know that the
adults care about them.
>>Felix: Before I transferred here,
I used to get in trouble a lot.
But like when I came to
Edwards, it was different
because everybody was focused,
and more serious about their work.
So I found that there was
no point of acting out,
and to take the work seriously
so you can be successful in life.